pensemos un poco más en cómo podemos
modelar el crecimiento poblacional y
mientras lo hacemos vamos a
familiarizarnos un poco con los tipos de
fórmulas que podemos encontrar en el
formulario de un examen ap de biología
en el vídeo anterior estudiamos la tasa
de crecimiento poblacional per cápita y
la representamos con la letra 'r' ahora
supongamos que la tasa de crecimiento
poblacional per cápita para una cierta
población es 0.2 esto significa que un
año después en promedio por cada
individuo la población crecerá en un 20%
dos décimas
así que un año después por cada
individuo habrá 1.2 de esa población y
recuerden que esto aplica tanto a las
poblaciones que se reproducen
sexualmente mediante un macho y una
hembra como a las poblaciones en donde
los individuos se pueden reproducir por
su cuenta al separarse en dos como
ocurre con los organismos unicelulares
con esto dicho ahora hablemos de un
concepto conocido como tasa máxima de
crecimiento poblacional per cápita para
este ejemplo vamos a decir que esta es
la tasa de crecimiento poblacional per
cápita si la población no es limitada es
decir existen recursos ilimitados como
agua comida terreno y lo que sea que
necesite la población para crecer pero
hasta ahí seguimos hablando de la tasa
de crecimiento poblacional per cápita en
donde no existen restricciones mientras
que aquí hablamos de una tasa máxima de
crecimiento y a partir de ahí vamos a
establecer una ecuación de crecimiento
exponencial como lo vimos en otros
vídeos acuérdense que en la tasa de
cambio de la población con respecto al
tiempo n es la población entonces de n
dt es la tasa de cambio de la población
con respecto al tiempo o también podemos
decir que es la tasa de crecimiento
poblacional lo escribiré
de crecimiento
poblacional
y suponiendo que estudiamos una
población que no está limitada por el
ecosistema lo cual no es realista pero
vamos a suponer que lo fuera entonces la
tasa de crecimiento poblacional será la
tasa máxima de crecimiento poblacional
per cápita por la población et así que
podemos crear una pequeña tabla para ver
cómo se relacionan esas dos cosas
pongamos la tabla pensemos en cómo será
la tasa de crecimiento poblacional
cuando la población es de 100 individuos
después cuando la población es de 500
individuos y finalmente cuando la
población es de 900 individuos entonces
dadas estas poblaciones cuál es la tasa
de crecimiento poblacional para cada una
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
bueno cuando la población es de 100
individuos la tasa de crecimiento
poblacional será igual a 0.2 por 100 lo
escribiré
nd te será igual a 0.2 la tasa máxima de
crecimiento poblacional per cápita por
la población neta que en este caso es
100 y esto es igual a 20 ok entonces
esto nos dice que cuando la población es
de 100 individuos por año la población
crecerá con 20 individuos más pero qué
pasa si la población es de 500
individuos cuál es la tasa de
crecimiento poblacional nuevamente pausa
en el vídeo y traten de resolver claro
simplemente tomamos la tasa máxima de
crecimiento poblacional per cápita y la
multiplicamos por la población neta
entonces al multiplicar 0.2 por 500
nuestra tasa de crecimiento poblacional
ahora es igual a 100 y si hablamos de
conejitos en años esto nos dice que
habrán 100 conejitos más por año o
simplemente 100 individuos más por año
finalmente veamos qué pasa cuando la
población eta es igual a 900 cuál será
la tasa de crecimiento poblacional pausa
en el vídeo bien simplemente
multiplicamos 0.2 por 900 y eso es igual
a 180 individuos por año ahora aquí
estamos hablando de una situación irreal
en donde una población crece sin
limitaciones pero en la vida real
sabemos que el terreno es limitado la
comida es limitada el agua es limitada y
para eso podemos hacer uso de la
capacidad de carga natural de una
población determinada en un medio
ambiente determinado para describirla
usaremos la letra k
entonces supongamos que los organismos
que estamos estudiando que son conejitos
se encuentran en una isla relativamente
pequeña y que la capacidad de carga
natural para esa isla es de mil
individuos
si la isla no puede soportar más de 1000
conejitos como podríamos cambiar esta
ecuación de crecimiento exponencial para
reflejar eso lo escribiré esta es la
ecuación de crecimiento exponencial
bueno lo que los matemáticos y biólogos
han hecho es que modifican esto
multiplicando lo por un factor para
obtener algo que se conoce como
crecimiento logístico crecimiento
logístico aquí hablamos del crecimiento
exponencial y ahora hablaremos de
crecimiento logístico para eso primero
empecemos con el crecimiento exponencial
la tasa de crecimiento poblacional se
puede ver como la tasa máxima de
crecimiento poblacional per cápita por
la población neta que es exactamente lo
que ya teníamos aquí pero ahora lo
multiplicamos por un factor para que
esto se ajuste conforme nos acercamos a
la capacidad de carga el factor que se
agrega es la capacidad de carga menos la
población neta entre la capacidad de
carga
veamos si esto es cierto hagamos
nuevamente una tabla con los mismos
valores iniciales
aquí tenemos en la población net y otra
vez queremos saber cuál es la tasa de
crecimiento poblacional cuando la
población sea de 100 500 y 900
individuos los invito a que pausa en el
vídeo y traten de calcular de n dt con
estos valores
vamos a ver escribiré el procedimiento
consciente
tenemos 0.2 por 100 por la capacidad de
carga que en este caso es 1000 menos 100
entre 1000 entonces esto es 900 entre
1000 que es igual a 0.9 y luego 0.2 por
100 es 20 entonces 20 por 0.9 es igual a
18 y miren eso es ligeramente menor a lo
que teníamos antes disminuye pero se
queda muy cerca
ahora veamos qué pasa cuando n es igual
a 500 pausa en el vídeo y calculen de n
dt para saber cuál será la tasa de
crecimiento poblacional con ese dato
bueno en este caso nos queda 0.2 por 500
por el factor que tenemos aquí que ahora
es 1000 menos 500 que ahora es nuestra
población y todo eso entre 1000 esto a
que es igual sabemos que esto es 100
porque ya lo teníamos pero ahora eso lo
multiplicamos por 500 500 entre 1000 que
es 0.5 así que ahora la población crece
a la mitad de lo que creció aquí porque
como les decía en realidad no hay
recursos infinitos entonces esto es
igual a 100 por 0.5 que es igual a 50
y si ahora analizamos este escenario
cuando la población es igual a 900 cuál
será de n dt nuevamente pausa en el
vídeo bueno en este caso será igual a
0.2 por 900 eso es 180 por el factor que
ahora es 1000 menos 900 entre 1000 así
que ahora este factor será igual a 100
entre 1000 que es 0.1 y esta parte es
igual a 180 entonces 180 por 0.1 es
igual a 18 la tasa de crecimiento
disminuyó porque miren aquí la tasa de
crecimiento poblacional siempre crece
porque entre más conejitos o individuos
existan hay más reproducción y por eso
la población crece exponencialmente pero
aquí al acercarse a la capacidad de
carga natural del medio ambiente en el
que nos encontramos observen que 900
está muy cerca
la capacidad lo que significa que muchos
conejitos tendrán hambre tal vez no se
sientan con ganas de reproducirse tanto
o tal vez muchos sean cazados o mueran
de inanición o si no tienen agua sufren
por deshidratación realmente no sabemos
qué podría pasar pero visualmente
podemos ver los datos con ayuda de una
gráfica aquí tenemos el tiempo y aquí la
población en el caso de crecimiento
exponencial lo podemos graficar así a
mayor población más rápido crece entre
más individuos hay más crece la
población y así infinitamente en teoría
no hay límite pero recuerden que esto no
es realista y en el caso del crecimiento
logístico usaré otro color al inicio el
crecimiento logístico se parece mucho a
un crecimiento exponencial pero es más
lento y después cuando la población
incrementa el crecimiento es aún más
lento y además se ve limitado por la
capacidad de carga
del medio ambiente así que nuestra casa
se encuentra aproximadamente aquí el
crecimiento se convierte en una especie
de assín total que no toca ese valor
porque si quisiéramos tocar el límite
que pasaría en este caso que le pasaría
a una población de mil individuos bueno
si fuera 1000 observen que este factor
sería cero por lo que en este punto la
población ya no crecería